[Music]
foreign
you're watching the Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making headlines with
the journalist and author Christina
Patterson and the former speechwriter at
number 10 ASA Bennett so let's take a
look at some of those front pages right
now we'll start with the front page of
the Sunday Times which leads with
findings of a cross parliamentary report
that the BBC chairman Richard Sharp
wasn't sufficiently transparent about
his personal dealings with former prime
minister Boris Johnson in the lead-up to
Sharp's appointment at the BBC
allegations that Mr Sharp denies
the Sunday Express has spoken to the
brother of Jamie Bulger who insists that
one of Jamie's Killers James venables
must never be released from Prism
the Sunday Mirror has an interview with
the former partner of the broadcaster
Vanessa Feltz
all the Sunday people reports that some
GP surgeries are being forced to close
early because they can't afford their
heating bills and according to the uh
daily start nudists are putting their
clothes on for this very same reason
now just to remind you that by scanning
the QR code that you see on your screen
during the program you can check the
front pages of the papers while you
watch along with us now tonight we're
joined by Christina Patterson and ASA
Bennett good evening to you both
Christina and ASA lovely to have you
with us on this Saturday evening let's
begin if we can with these Sunday Times
uh Christina and this is the uh
reporting that's coming from the digital
culture media and Sport committee that
um the BBC chairman may have undermined
trust in the BBC by not being entirely
forthcoming with everything that was
going on when he was talking to Boris
Johnson and Sam Blythe about that 800
000 pound credit facility
yes well it's a pretty damning report it
it claims that he fell well short of the
standards that would generally be
expected and that he has undermined
confidence in the whole public
appointment system and I have to say
that that is certainly I I think both of
those things are accurate I think the
whole thing has undermined confidence in
the public appointment system although I
think confidence in the public
appointment system in recent years
particularly under Boris Johnson had
dropped radically anyway because there
was a sense that so many of the
appointments were basically given to
cronies and people who had voted for
brexit they were given it seems quite
often more on people's political
allegiances than necessarily on their
skills and experience and talent for the
job and Richard Sharp has issued a kind
of standard non-apology in which he says
something like
um I'm sorry if the committee felt that
I didn't reach you know offer the degree
of transparency that they would have
liked and you know know when people are
basically not sorry they say that sorry
they're sorry the other person was
offended or took it you know it was mad
enough to think they had done something
wrong when in fact they hadn't done
something wrong so I don't think that
will placate anyone and um the Lucy
Powell the shadow uh culture secretary
has said he should consider his opinion
I suspect he will Brazen this one out
and I suspect he will stay but I think
it not only has undermined faith in the
public appointment system but also has
caused a lot of disquiet and distress at
the BBC thanks for that Christina and
they said what do you think uh a
non-apology from sharp as Christina says
and and the reporting in this article as
well just lays out to remind us that
this is the first sort of look at this
situation there are two other reports
into Mr Sharp that are ongoing
hmm I think the culture committee
clearly are feeling a bit sore after
when they first interviewed Mr Sharp uh
saying basically that he was an
excellent appointment and this included
uh labor members and it was unanimous
verdicting like and so now this has
turned sharply um and that does a very
accidental pun apologies I move on
um because they've realized that they
asked him openly
um you know was there anything they
needed to know about these things and
the ideal moments you may argue to
volunteer such matters
um clear the answer came there none but
now we find from the Sunday Times as
reporting which is very much LED on this
uh that you know any belated
acknowledged that CD he he made he sort
of apologized for not being so
forthcoming
um but as a result uh what we see is
that you know the npcd he has you know
there were lapses of judgment
um they've stopped short of calling in
to resign over any sort of pretense or
appearance of being to to close some
compromising any sense of neutrality for
the BBC chairman needs to help maintain
but they've certainly you know let's put
it this way and they're not calling for
him to fall on the sword but they
definitely wave you know putting the
sword out in front of him and seeing
what he'll do okay let's move on to
another story that's making news
tomorrow we've been uh covering it today
Christina and this is in the Sunday
Express
um this is the situation that happened a
couple nights ago
um or rather last night actually in
merseyside and violence Outsider Hotel
housing Asylum Seekers
yes and it's it sounds like a rather
volatile situation there are protesters
and violence outside a hospital in
knowsley in merseyside following
um an alleged incident of some kind of
sexual nature it's not clear exactly
what happened but it seems that
um someone who may or may not be an
asylum Seeker but who's being put up in
this accommodation
um behaved inappropriately to a teenager
and that has stoked up an enormous
amount of anger on social media and
actually
um on the streets now in in relation to
violence and even Zoella uh bravaman who
is not known for wanting to discourage
um criticism of Asylum Seekers and um as
she would call them illegal immigrants
um even she has said look you know it's
time to calm things down I what this
brings to mind to me is
um a number of incidents in Germany and
in Scandinavia where where there were um
a lot of there were a number of sexual
assaults by Asylum Seekers often from
the Middle East and that caused enormous
amounts of
um unease and anger because sometimes
for political reasons those assaults
were not publicized in the Press so
certainly in Sweden that happened rather
shockingly so that nobody is saying that
there is a math problem with Asylum
Seekers this looks like one incident and
we don't even know if it actually
happened but what it does show is how
much um resentment there is in certain
communities about so-called illegal
immigration and how easily that can tip
over into something really quite ugly
yeah we've got as Christina says we've
got no idea ASA about what um actually
brought those people out the truth of
what actually brought those people out
we have seen the aftermath of those
people being outside uh that uh Hotel uh
just as Christine was saying they're
really it lays out so the difficulties
of dealing with the issue and also the
dangers of rumors running rampant on
social media
absolutely and we've seen what happens
when this spreads completely out of
control uh the reports show that a
police van will satellite and missiles
were thrown no one seems to have been
injured thankfully um but then clearly
arrests were made as protesters were
clashing
um we're talking about not just the far
right but also then you know pro-refugee
activists
um and they've they've been saying that
you know talking about how so terrifying
it was and that's where the war zone
quote comes from um I think I was very
struck by a quote from the local MP who
basically made clear that you know the
people that were warned and reminded us
that you know the facts are very few at
the moment it's not clear why this is
happening but one thing is clear is that
you know these protesters you know the
far right in particular do not represent
the community okay Acer Christina just
pause for me a second there because I
want to bring our viewers some breaking
news out of the Brits where it's been
announced that Harry Styles has won this
year's uh album of the year it adds to
three other awards that he took home
this evening including song of the year
and artists of the year we'll have all
the latest on those Brit Awards
from our arts and entertainment
correspondents in the next hour so Harry
Styles there winning album of the year
at this year's Brits
all right in a moment I'm going to ask
you both for your favorite Harry Styles
song but let's move on with a paper
review uh Christina let's go on to uh
something inside the Sunday Express here
and this is all about these sussexes
apparently lining up uh new Big Money
contracts tell us about this
well I mean they've got 16 bathrooms to
clean in the Mansion they're living in
and I imagine that's quite expensive
um so they had I think it was something
like 60 let me check it was something
like
82.7 million dollar deal with Netflix
and more with Spotify and uh various
contracts lined up and of course Harry's
uh Harry's book spare was one of the
biggest non-fiction biggest selling
fastest selling non-fiction books of all
time and the Netflix series did very
well so clearly
um dish in the dirt on their family and
particularly in Harry's case on his
brother and father has proved very
lucrative for him and the hope is it
will it will continue to prove lucrative
and apparently there are going to be all
kinds of possibly record-breaking offers
for him to be a pundit on the day of the
coronation in America and to do all
kinds of presenting and speaking so you
know I just hope that all this money
makes him happy because so far he seems
to be one of the unhappiest extremely
rich people in the world and it's a real
shame to see someone who is so in love
with with his wife and who has clearly
two lovely children living in a
beautiful place in a sunny country with
apparently friends around them be so
miserable I absolutely feel for the pain
he went through in relation to his
mother and the paparazzi but I really
think enough of this misery and I just
hope that whatever he does next focuses
on something more positive all right
we're going to leave it there run out of
time I can see noddling along with some
of that Aces over appreciate that
Christina thank you for telling us about
that story about the sussexes and uh and
other contracts to earn a bit more money
in the express now so to come how high
heating bills are affecting many people
all across the country will discuss how
they're coping or not when we get back
[Music]
hello there and welcome back you're
watching the Press preview uh joining us
are Christina Patterson and ASA Bennett
and there they are in the big screen
Christina good to have you both with us
thanks for sticking around all right
let's go to the front page of the Sunday
people now and they've got a story there
about the cost of living crisis uh
Christina and how um this is really the
effect on NHS and GP surgeries
particularly apparently some can't
afford to keep the heating on
yes well according to this story some um
GP surgeries are limiting their opening
hours because they can't afford as you
just said to to heat their surgeries uh
that will be very bad news for a lot of
patients because I think many people
struggle to see a GP anyway often
there's a kind of mad rush to have to
call it eight o'clock in the morning and
then you can't get through and then and
then you you have you know to wait
several weeks I have to say that it's
not I'm very lucky in in that my GP
surgery is very good and I've been
seeing the same GP largely for about 20
years which is probably quite unusual
and that's in a very very busy uh GP
surgery in Hackney but um but you know
the the cost of living crisis is causing
problems for everyone and if it's
affecting people's ability to see a GP
it will affect their health and that
will have a spiraling effect to the
already many many problems we're facing
in this country so very far from ideal
absolutely right and they say it kind of
brings to mind as well the sort of the
recent stories we've had about GPS
particularly you know were caused to
work longer hours from from parts of
parts of the media also ideas about
um changing the way that GB practices
operate it's just the increased pressure
that we're seeing on General
Practitioners
absolutely and we've seen in Health
Service recently
um you know all sorts of professionals
going out on strike in order to try to
improve their pay conditions and so I
think it's this sort of perfect storm
that they're facing at the moment of you
know cost of living going through the
roof Energy prices being at you know
recently at record highs although we
expect no they will certainly start to
ease as we get into the summer
um and it's clearly the government has
met that's why the government's made
clear it's one of their big priorities
to try and you know Bear Down on the
backlog and you know that would get help
hit so that people can start to see
their GPS start to get the appointments
they need
and there is also of course I think last
time you and I spoke Christina there was
the course so pay to see a GPU do you
think we're we're likely to start seeing
more calls to try and change the way
that people
um get access to their nearest doctor
that's a
a key one to answer actually because I
think it has so enshrined into the DNA
of this country that the NHS is always
free at the point of delivery to
everyone and
um I think you know Studies have been
done into the possible consequences of
charging people for GPS visits and what
the conclusion has been that the poorest
who's whose health is generally the
worst for all kinds of reasons
um then end up not seeing doctors at all
and the obviously they suffer much worse
health and then the the bill that the
country ends up paying it is much higher
so it is a very complicated issue I mean
I'm all in favor of uh you know the NHS
I think it certainly has been one of the
glories of this country but it isn't
working very well at the moment and I
think we have to do some things
differently and interestingly I think
we're streating the shadow Health
secretary has some very interesting and
quite bold ideas about what to do about
the NHS and GP surgeries and in a way
that perhaps the conservatives don't
dare talk about because they can't be
seen to be privatizing the NHS because
uh because of this sense that the NHS is
a national religion so I think we'll
we'll have to see what happens but you
know clearly there are a lot of people
who are struggling to see a GP at the
moment lots of people struggling to see
anyone at the moment in healthcare terms
and that is very worrying when health
health standards of Health in this
country are dropping radically anyway
yeah and they said there are some calls
from from gdp's themselves who perhaps
want to try and uh change the fact that
they have to sort of manage the entire
practice and other local surgeries as
well
um and as well as this there's obviously
the calls that you know Bubble Up about
you know charging people for missing
appointments uh I think even sooner
suggested that last year
um as a way to try and make sure that
what is expected of GPS is then a more
efficient and appropriate load um I
think the chief problem
um Health associations have been Claire
is that it's administratively fiendish
to try and Implement a scheme um there's
also discussions about you know whether
GPS then should be paid by how many
patients they see or you know in other
sort of or having patients on their
books
um so I'm sure this debate will rumble
on